hello david speaking uh hello hello
jacob it's uh
dougie here from tvnz how are you doing
yeah good thank you how are you doing
good good i just spoke to uh your
brother is it ollie
yeah yeah olly yeah yeah and he sounds
pretty excited about this opportunity
that we have uh for both you and him
has he spoken to you yet
no i haven't had the chance to speak
from yet okay well let me let me just
fill you in
um i'm in charge of tv content for uh
tvnz
yeah and we've been hanging out for uh
sports show for a very long time
and my idea is sort of a star brother
challenge
where we can get uh big name brothers to
do challenges
oh okay
so we've got some big names on board
julian and adi
baldi body said no but we've got scott
and jordy
we're waiting on rico and akira
to come through today maybe
so that we're hoping to get you and
ollie because i mean
now that you're new zealand maori and so
is your brother you're both big names
now
well and i appreciate that how would
that sound
yeah yeah cool yeah well um what what
would i have to do for it sorry
yeah oh yeah i'll get there uh so it
will be filmed after the bunnings cup
and it will be filmed over three days
but it would be played over a seven week
period on the tv
yeah and it would involve just lots of
different
challenges oh yeah so we've got some
ideas on challenges like a tandem bungee
jump
uh mudslides uh
let birds eat bread off you
lots lots of great challenges
i guess the thing that's uh stopping a
couple of the boys from playing is
it is going to be a later show sir um we
were going to do the challenges naked
native yeah but your bits would be
blanked out for the tv
i mean dog roll barrett was super keen
slongdong ollie was he loved the idea
yeah
oh interesting
i'll have a chat to him but yeah so
you've called them today have you yeah i
just caught them before you oh cool
you you so you're pretty keen or does
the naked part sort of pick you off
no no i'm i want you i'll chat to him
okay
but yeah i'll get do i just get back to
you on this number oh yeah that would be
great thanks jacob
but that'll yeah i'll chat to him and
then yeah i'll get back to you on his
number yeah
so
do you think you'd beat the other
brothers
oh i'd love to give it with a good track
i think you guys would be tough to beat
especially the size of your place um
is there a um certain time that you want
me to get back to you for some time this
week yeah sometime this week there's no
rush i mean it's not filmed till after
the bunning so
i'm totally up to you
okay easy as perfect oh yeah we'll chat
to all in here i'll get back to this
number hey you're a good man thank you
jacob
no no worries
see you soon
hello jacob hey sorry jacob
no no word i forgot a couple of things i
forgot to talk about the money
oh man oh well okay
now how much would you want
oh well
um
i haven't really thought about that part
to be honest you just give me a number
really isn't that simple we'll make it
happen
oh okay oh yeah can i have a think about
that as well no give me a number now
jacob we need a plan
i need i need time to think about it
it was jackie
oh no way
[Laughter]
oh sorry jack i didn't know you're gonna
be so
[Laughter]
i've just cute in class 2 and i just was
like
oh see this is why i hate picking up
randomly
never answer
oh my you've done well then
oh i was just like hang on like always
did nothing
i couldn't leave it i had to call you
back i was like oh we've got through
that too easy
oh you just you just hit tv and i was
like oh no
[Laughter]
when you were like when you're like oh
you and ollie will go against you and i
was like hang on big
oh you're a good man
i love you i said oh i still haven't
seen that coming
i've tried a few guys today
oh i was cracking up when you're like oh
and naked so i was like
oh you're a good kid